مجزره وظيفيه في فيسبوك فصل 11 الف موظف
وارشيف ال 60 عاما
لفنان العرب الصفقه الاغلى عالميا وجدل
ماسك وتويتر مستمر ازمه في الانتخابات
النصفيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
تناولنا من يومين معلومات عن نيه متى انها
تسرح عدد من موظفيها بسبب تراجع سعر
اسهمها بنسبه 70 في ال 100 وارتفاع معدل
الانفاق الجديد اليوم واللي ممكن نسميه
العنوان العريض على خطه تويتر متى بتسرح
موظفيها في اليوم متى سرحت فعليا اكثر من
11,000 موظف من سبعه وثمانين الف موظف
يعني 13% وهذه العمليه هي الاكبر والاوسع
من الوقت تاسيس ماتا من 18 سنه الرئيس
التنفيذي لمن ماركذكر برج الرساله
للموظفين وقال فيها انه هذه التغيرات من
اصعب التغييرات في تاريخ الشركات وشرح
الاسباب اللي خلت الشركه انها توصل الى
هذا القرار واللي من بينها النتائج
العكسيه اللي ما توقعها بسبب انكماش او
انكماش اقتصاد الكلي
بعد رائحه كورونا والخطوات السريعه اللي
اتخذها هذا غير المنافسه من بعض التطبيقات
وخساره اشاره الاعلانات في نظام اي او اس
اللي تسببت في انخفاض عائدات متى وقال ان
هو بيتحمل مسؤوليه ذلك وقال مايك في رساله
انه الموظفين المشرحين راح يوصل لهم بريد
الكتروني بفقدان عملهم ابتداء من صباح
اليوم وراح يحصلوا على راتب اربع شهور
واجر اسبوعين اضافيين عن كل سنه من الخدمه
كان نوع من التعويض عن فقدانهم عملهم
وتحدث عن انهم اكثر الاقسام اللي راح
تتضرري التسويق والشراكه والموارد البشريه
وحقيقه في معلومات كانت متداوله لانه في
خيمه امل كبير عند ماركه بسبب مشروع متى
بس اللي يكلف الشركه السته 30 مليار دولار
ولكنه ما جاب الايرادات المطلوبه وكان اجل
ب 300,000 مستخدم عن الهدف المتوقع في
نهايه السنه والسبب هي انه اغلب التقارير
بتقول ان المستخدمين بعد دخولهم للواقع
الافتراضي بيعانه من مشاكل صحيه وغثيان
وحتى صداع مستمر وارتبطت هذه الخساره
بخساره وحده اعمال يصير لابس اللي بتشرف
على انشطه الواقع الافتراضي والواقع
المعزز ب 9.4 مليار دولار وكانت اسهم متى
بتراجعت كمان بنسبه 26% اليوم وكل هذه
التطورات
جعلت من متى حسب التقرير سي ام بي سي
الشركه
الاسواد اداء هذا العام
عبر الزوم ينضم الى الرياض المحرر التقني
في اندبندنت عربيه عبد الله السبع اهلا
فيك معانا عبد الله يعني يعني الناس كانت
مصدومه من الاقالات الجلسه بتصير في تويتر
جا يعني دخل فيسبوك ومارك ذكر برج وقال لك
11000 ايش اللي بيحصل هذا
التقنيه
كثيره
موجوده حاليا في السوق بدات توقف عمليه
التوظيف بشكل كامل ابل مايكروسوفت
التوظيف بشكل كامل الا في بعض الاقسام
البسيطه طبعا المشاكل اللي مرت فيها خلال
سنوات الماضيه
وبعدها انخفاض والتضخم ثلاث سنوات الماضيه
ادت ان الشهر العسل ينتهي بشكل فعلي ما
بين همم شركه تقنيه وما بين الصعود الكبير
جدا في الارباح خمس سنوات الماضيه كل
الشركات التقنيه خلال السنوات الماضيه او
بدايه
صعود جدا
كبيره لانها ما قعدت تنمو
الموظفينها فيسبوك شبكه اجتماعيه عندها
اكثر من 85,000 موظف حول العالم فلذلك
اكيد تعاني مشاكل بسبب قوانين خصوصيه
جديده في اغلب الشركه قله العوائد
الاعلانيه ومشاكل جدا وهو كمان يعني جاك
دورسي
اعلن انه حيسرح كثير من الموظفين جاك
ترسله واحد من مؤسسين تويتر اعتذر وقال
انه هذه غلطته لانه هو كبر الشركه اكثر
مما ينبغي فيبدا انه هذه كمان برده مشكله
عامه شعره في وقت العسل زي ما ذكرت انه
يقدر ويكبروا الان بيدفعوا الثمن طيب اذا
قارن لنا كل هذا الشركات التيك توك هل
التيك توك بواجه نفس هذه المشاكل
لا تك تك خلال السنوات الماضيه قاعدين
ينمو
كبير ومضطر لكن لازم نعرف شيء
مو لان يعني قاعد يسوي شيء خارق جديده في
المنصات الجديده
الناس تبحث عن بدا
ئل الماضيه
اي من الصح حاليا تقدم اي خدمه جديده ممكن
ما تلاقي رواتب المستخدمين لازم كمان نعرف
شيء شركه ابل شركه مايكروسوفت خلال سنوات
الماضيه ما قدمت شيء جدا كبير او ثوري صح
يعني ابو من خلال عشر سنوات الماضيه قدمت
سماعه ابل قدمت ساعه ابل لكن بعدها ما
بدنا نشوف من شغلات
قبل السيارات لكنه ما بدها تطبق بشكل جدا
كبير بدات تتوسع في
خدمات الدفع من خلال ابل لكنه حتى الان ما
في شيء ثوري قاعد يكون فيسبوك راحت على
الواقع الافتراضي وفشلت فيه لانه كل
الشركات حاليا تدور على البيض اللي قاعد
او الدجاج
اللي يتعلم الفرصه الذهبيه اللي تطلعهم من
دائره الركود الى دائره النمو بشكل كبير
ااه الفيسبوك كانت متامله لان الواقع
الافتراضي همم هو يكون هو المجال اللي هو
ينجحوهم فيه لكن للاسف خلال سنوات الماضيه
قاعدين يبقى كل فتره انه المسار اللي هم
اتخذوهم مسار خاطئهم ممكن انه لما يكون هو
النجاح حابه اتوقف تحديدا عن موضوع اللي
هو
المتوفيس الواقع الافتراضي وكذا لانه وقت
لما طلع يعني الكل اتكلم انه خلاص احنا
هنترك عالمنا ده وهنروح في العوالم
الثانيه هذه والناس الشركات بدات تشتري
هناك محلات واراضي ومباني وما الى ذلك طيب
الان كانه يعني هذا اسوء وافشل مشروع في
التاريخ
شوفي الواقع الافتراضي قد يكون مستمر عند
الناس والناس تقدر تستخدم لكن مو بنفس
الطريقه الي نحن عارفينها الان خليني
ارجعلك الى بدايه الالفيه الماضيه كيف
كانت اشكال الكمبيوتر
ما هي كانت هذه الطريقه اللي ممكن تنجح
فيها كان في جوالك لمس موجوده لكنها كانت
تعتمد على نظام ويندوز كانت تعتمد على
الانظمه مختلفه وكانت تعتمد على القلم لمن
جئت افضل جوجل وغيرت مجال الهواتف الذكيه
وبدها تشجع الناس انهم يستخدم
قاعد تمشي عليه ما اتوقع انه راح ينجح
يمكن يكون عليه جدا كبيره حتى الان اللي
قاعدين بشكل كبير غير رهان اللي اخذتها
سناب شات اللي يقول واقع المعززه من
الواقع اللي احنا عايشين ايوه
مجال قاعدين ينجح وقاعد يكبر بشكل كبير قد
ينمو خلال السنوات القادمه زي ما تنوي
سناب شات انها تنمو خلال سنوات القادمه
لكن الواقع الافتراضي قد يكون ناجح خلال
خمس سنوات قادمه لكن مو بالشكل اللي احنا
نعرفه ومو بشكل او الطريقه اللي قاعد
نستخدمها الفتره الحاليه طيب احنا هنشوف
تراجع يبدو من مارك ذكر برك على هذا
الموضوع لانه يعني يبدو هو كان اكثر واحد
متحمس لهذا الموضوع
الطريقه اللي راح يتقبل فيها المستخدم
الواقع الافتراضي بشكل جميل جدا
اي شخص يستخدم الواقع يعني من صداع يعاني
من غثيان يعاني من مشاكل جدا مختلفه ما
تقدر تعيش في هذا العالم اكثر من 45 دقيقه
الفيسبوك نفسه حاليا في مذكره داخليه
كانوا يشكون انا من عزوف الموظفين من
استخدام منصه والدخول عليها لما هم نفسهم
يدخلوا عليها طيب يعني اذا تتذكر عبد الله
قبل كم سنه كانت كل الدراسات اللي جلسه
بتطلع ومثلا كل الاشياء اللي يقول لك
الوظيفه الحلم وما الى ذلك كلهم كانوا
بيذكروا انه التوظيف في هذه الشركات مثلا
جوجل فيسبوك او متى وهذه الشركات التقنيه
بيقول لك انه هذا هو احسن مجال في همم
للتوظيف فعليا هل الان لا زالوا الاحسن في
هذا المجال ولا طلع من الموضوع لا كله زي
بعضه
هو لازالت تعتبر من الشركات الكبيره كل
شركات التقنيه تعتبر من الشركات الكبيره
وتعتبر يعني على قولتهم خيار امثل للتوظيف
لكن التضخم الكبير اللي صار خلال سنوات
الماضيه وايضا التوظيف الغير محسوب عواقبه
سبب مثل هذه المشاكل في شركات نجت من هذه
المشكله في شركات كبيره ما سمعنا اسماءهم
استغلت عن الموظفين ليه لان كانوا
الموظفين فيها المدروس عكس بقيه الشركات
اللي كان النمو بشكل كبير جدا كبير وكانت
في قرارات جدا لو رجعنا خلال همم سنوات
الماضيه كانت شركات تعمل في مجال الاغذيه
ما بدي استنى اسم بعينه لكن شركات تعمل في
مجال الاغديه كانت تعتبر الحلم وكانت
مغريه جدا كبيره للمستثمرين
اصبحت اقل همم اغراء بسبب انه وصلت الى
المرحله اللي اقصى شيء ممكن توصله فهل هذه
المرحله هي اقصى شيء ممكن توصل لها
الشركات التقنيه اتوقع ان الشركات التقنيه
لا زال عندها مجال خاصه مايكروسوفت وابل
جوجل بسبب اعتمادهم على مختلف تقنيات
وايضا وجود فرصه جدا ذهبيه في المنازل
الذكيه خاصه مع اطلاق ما ترز او منصه
ماترز ذكيه ايضا موجود فرصه جدا كبيره في
الذكاء الصناعي وجود فرصه اكثر كثير في
مجال السيارات ذاتيه القياده فلذلك اتوقع
انه مستقبل افضل مايكروسوفت وجوجل وامازون
قد يكون مريح اكثر من الشبكات التواصل
اجتماعيهم لانه الشبكات التواصل اجتماعيه
قاعد تمر بمرحله الكود جدا كبيره خلال
فتره الماضيه مع مشاكل خصوصيه وقله
الاعلانات واتجاه كنا محتوى الى من الصادق
منافسه فلذلك الان همم اللعبه تغيرت في
مجال المرصات ما اتوقع في امور كثيره
تتغير خلال سنوات القادمه غير المشاكل
السياسيه اللي كلهم داخلين فيها يعني غصبا
عنهم او بارادتهم طيب على العموم احنا
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا عبور من
الرياضه المحرر التقني في العربيه عبد
الله السابقه شكرا لك عبد الله
منافسه شرسه بتشهد الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه اللي شاغل العالم وتصدرت بسببها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه للتراند
والاخبار والعناوين الانتخابات اللي بدات
امس وانتهت صباح اليوم وكانت الاغلبيه
فيها لصالح الجمهوريين من مجلس النواب
والمنافسه ما زالت على اشدها على مقاعد
مجلس الشيوخ وبين من العالم كله
النتائج كمان في ناس جلسه بتترقب نشره
اخبار الماسك اليوميه واذا كان مصر حكم
الفقر تفعيل العلامه الزرقاء اللي تاجل
اللي بعد الانتخابات تفاديا لموضوع امتحان
الهويه وتسييس للانتخابات لصالح حزب دون
الاخر او يعني على الاقل هذا هو الشيء
المعلن اللي هم قالوه وبعدين النقطه
بالتحديد كانت جدد الامس بسبب تغريده
انشرها ماسك اوصى فيها الامريكيين
بالتصويت للجمهوريين باعتبار انه الرئاسه
لديمقراطيين وارفقها كمان بتغريده الثانيه
ان المنتخب من المستقلين هم اللي بيقرروا
نتائج الانتخابات هذه التغريدات عملت حاله
من الانقسام والجدري في الاراء ففي ناس
شافت انه يعني انت لغيت قرار التنسيق
التوثيق علشان موضوع التسييس وانت جالس
منشور بترجلس يعني بتنشر وبتكتب منشورات
وتغريدات كلها تسييس وفي ناس شافت لا عادي
ترى مواطن قولوا حق التعبير عن رايه زيه
زي غيره نتيجه هذا الجدل طلع ماسك ابرر
ووضح انه هو طول عمره مستقل ما بيتبعل
للجمهوريين ولا الديمقراطين ولكن تاريخ
الانتخابي لغايه السنه هذه كان مع
الديمقراطيين في انه كان بيصوت لهم ولكن
قال كمان ان هو منفتح على التصويت مره
اخرى للديمقراطيين في المستقبل
بالاضافه لتصدر اسم الماسك الاخبار بسبب
تويتر والتوثيق وغيرها كمان كان في لشركه
السيارات اللي بيمتلكها ماسك اللي هي تسلا
طبعا نصيب من الاخبار اليوم من بعد ما تم
تداول المعلومات انه ماسك باع اسهم في
تسلق بقيمه 4 مليار دولار واللي اظهرت
هيئه الاوراق الماليه والبورسات الامريكيه
انه ماسك مول جزء كبير من صفقات تويتر عبر
بيعوا لاسهم في بلغت قيمتها ما يقارب
ثلاثه مليار دولار
للمستثمرين
انه ماسك بيهتم بالتويتر اكثر منهن هو على
فكره شركه تسلم فقدت نصف قيمتها في السوق
من ابريل الماضي كمان
الم من جديد في اغلى صفقه في العالم
العربي حصلت شركه روتانا للصوتيات مرئيات
على حقوق استثمار المصنفات والمحتوى الفني
للفنان العرب محمد عبده كتالوج الاغاني
المؤرشفه اللي استلمته روتانا بدون 122
البوم وفيه من بنى اغاني يمكن يتم اعاده
التسجيلها العقد اللي تم توقيعه بين شركه
الفنان الخاصه صوت الجزيره وبين شركه
روتانا ونتائج تاريخ فنان العرب على مدى
60 عام وراح تشرف روتانا على اداره
المحتوى والاستفاده منه بافضل طريقه
المستشار تركي ال الشيخ كان له كلمه خلال
المؤتمر الصحفي اللي تم الاعلان في عن
الصفقه واللي اكد خلالها على اهميه هذه
الخطوه واهميه الارث الفنيه
الفنان محمد عبده ليس فنان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بس وابرز فنان في الوطن
العربي وابرز فنان في الشرق الاوسطه من
الابرز في العالم
تاريخيا وانتاجيا وشهره
فالارشيف لشركه الخاصه اللي كانت بتسمى
شركه صوت الجزيره
انتقل بالكتالوج كامل للروتانا لاداره
المحتوى والاستفاده منه فيه كثير من
الفنانين الكبار احنا واجهنا صعوبه سواء
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي الوطن
العربي بعد عمر طويل او بعد اعتزالهم او
بعد الله يطول عمرك يا محمد يعني او بعد
اعتزالهم او بعد اي شيء
نواجه صعوبات ما عائلتهم او مع تقدير هذا
الارث الفني او الاستفاده منه الان الارث
هذا بشيء في ايادي امينه في شركه وطنيه
سعوديه تستفيد منه اللي يحب اقوله انه
برضه لا زال الفنان الكبير محمد عبده
لازال يحطوا كل الارقام القياسيه هذا اغلى
ارشيف اتباع انا ما راح اعلن الرقم
لارشيف فنان في تاريخ الشرق الاوسط ويمكن
من الاغلى في العالم
كلها كانت مخزنه ومحفوظه
لانه ظهرت تكنولوجيا جديده في همم في
القرن الجديد اللي هو 20 على راسها روتانا
طبعا
روتانا اليوم
الوحيده التي تقدر هذا وتسمى هذا الشيء
وبدور على شركه روتانا عبر رئيسا سالم
الهندي شكرت الفنان محمد عبده على اختياره
لها واكدت انها راح تكون امينه على ارشيف
والفنيه
ابو ناصر مع المستشار تركي ال الشيخ
بصراحه كان هو يعني
عراب الصفقه هذه اللي صارت مع الفنان
العرب محمد عبده هذه الصفقه طبعا يعني
المحتوى الفني الثاني لفنان العرب في خلال
60 عام يعني انتقل الى شركه روتانا وان
شاء الله يعني احنا نكون امين على هذا
المحتوى
باذن الله يعني ان هذا المحتوى نحافظ عليه
كنا احنا كمان اكبر شركه انتاج الوطن
العربي الشركه السعوديه كمان
فان شاء الله يا رب الله يوفقنا
وطبعا من بعد ما تم الاعلان عن هذه الصفقه
كثير من الفنانين رتوه تغريده المستشار
تركي ال الشيخ اللي اعلن فيها عن توقيع
العقود وابره من الصفقه وتفاعلوا مع الخبر
واعتبروها خطوه مهمه للفن السعودي
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
من اترككم مع لمحه من التاريخ الاستثنائي
لمحبوب الفنان او المحبوب الملايين اللي
فنان العرب محمد عبده في امان الله
يا حبيبي
انا انا
استناني
ربي تمم لنا انسانا انسانا
يا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
انستنا ان
ستا
في بالك انها الليله عرفتك بس ماضي وفجري
وليله زي بالليل
بالامل عمري
الليله اه بس مكتوبه
[موسيقى]
الامل عمري
والبسمه
مكانك ولا الاحساس
يا ريت الدنيا
صارتني وكل الناس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ريان
[موسيقى]
ريانه العود
عريانه العود
[موسيقى]
لا تعرف